they're being ushered back into their
own country but it isn't a happy
homecoming
just a few days ago these guatemalans
were in the united states now they've
been turned back
first u.s authorities flew them deep
into southern mexico to try and prevent
them crossing the border again
then mexican authorities bust them
further back into carmen a guatemala
border village
there's a mixture of confusion and
disappointment here
they sent us back here without signing
deportation papers without asking us
anything not even the address where we
were going they just had us four days in
the cooler in cold rooms and then they
sent us back to guatemala just like that
it's all happening under a u.s health
provision called title 42 being used in
the pandemic to turn back migrants
without allowing them to ask for asylum
now they've been dropped here even
though they don't really know where here
is you don't know where you are
i don't really know this part of the
border helen told us her family was from
the paten department
afterwards i found out that was a 15
hour drive away i asked her at the time
how she get home
i don't know because i've got no money
they took us by surprise just saying go
now
the us is struggling with high border
numbers and overcrowding in its
facilities it's told people not to come
i want to be clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making that dangerous trek
to the united states mexico border
do not come
do not come
but that's being drowned in a sea of
misinformation in facebook forums and
from people smugglers who profit from
those desperate for a better life they
charged wilbur more than ten thousand
dollars to take him north he was betting
on reaching the states to pay that money
back
now he has to do it in a country where
he can't find work
in guatemala there's no money so we go
north trying for a better future for our
children
we don't have money to get them to
school now we're coming back with a big
debt and without money or work
he has his son little wilbur with him
wilbur's two other siblings are still
stateside with their mother we left him
trying to find a way back to his home
six hours away it's the end of the
flights for this evening at least but
for the people on the other side of that
bridge back in guatemala it's just going
to be the start of working out how to
get home and in many of their cases how
are they going to start paying off the
amount of money that they borrowed to
pay people smugglers to get them to the
united states so for them this is far
from the end john holman al jazeera
talisman